[Music]
okay welcome to endgame exclam double X
plan or somebody pointed out XXX clan
because there's exclaimed in the title
followed by 2x clans okay so today's
theme is good to be me so it's gonna be
my games although I do know that I am
teaching a chess camp this week or for
you at home a year ago and uh my other
co teacher person I played him before
you were born and I'm going to show that
game to it because I want okay so this
game was played in 1990 and I had the
black pieces like with black on the
bottom that way if you know who shows up
we're good so we have a red pawn endgame
and the question is should I trade rooks
sure he trade rooks at W a Brooks and
this position I played the movie six and
it's like smooth so I put the onus on
white and the engine today's engine this
game was played 27 years ago so I don't
the engine said then it probably said
what's an engine it says this is an
equal position if white plays the
correct move but what the engine says
and what a grandmaster like ken west
would think is different much different
because let's say for example every move
you play draws and your opponent has one
move that draws in every position well
then you're better because you have easy
draw and your opponent has to find the
right move every time so the engine says
this is a draw and it says equal but
white only has one way to draw and the
move that it wants white to play seems a
little iffy to me it's probably a move
that I wouldn't play so I guess if I was
white I would have lost two yeah okay so
white loss did a forced way and
grandmasters have a saying so you can
you can take a napkin West because you
you know this yeah when you go into a
king upon ending when it's not a king of
one ending and you decide to go into it
you have to be a hundred percent sure
and it's hard to be 100 percent sure
unless you already know the position
because there's a lot of King upon
endings where you say something la
mulana up but you're still losing or
easily drawing when you should have
stayed on the other end game now here my
Kings better than his King my Kings of
the fourth rank is Kings on the third
rank and my King is next to one of his
pawns and his King is not near any of my
pawns so I prefer black and let's see if
anybody the audience can guess what move
the engine wants to play for white not
not Ken Wasco that's not fair you know
somebody else
what should white do who has the courage
of their convictions to suggest a move
not I I use the engine even at home
they're quiet they're like don't call on
me because they know I will call on them
at home I've done it before anybody
Euler I give a long preamble you guys
should have like analyzed it out when I
was doing that okay h4 that's a move
that's the interesting with actually
that puts sort of pressure on black to
do something yeah no but h4 is a Force's
black to make a decision whether to take
upon the plate g4 okay so this move
wouldn't be the first move on my radar
but it wants to play F takes G five and
I think the idea is you're taking a pond
that's always a good idea now White has
some extra squares for his rock that you
didn't have before and we can't take the
pawn now we legally can but then Rick
takes e5 check is good so the computers
calculated a million moves ahead and has
concluded that this position is a draw
and if I was white I'd be really scared
here
because I have a past pond and white
doesn't so and my kings on the fourth
day it seems on the third-ranked
so if I was a betting man I would just
say that blacks winning but the computer
just calculates all the way to the end
of the game as a draw so but yeah if I
was playing I can't imagine I was
playing I can't imagine
very many people would do that because
you basically have to see all the way to
the end and you're tricky vehicle you're
lost because I have a passed pawn and
you don't and my Kings better than yours
okay
age score is probably the second best
move my point played one that loses
immediately so that he's just lost and
he made a move that you really shouldn't
make unless you're really really really
sure he played rook takes before yeah
and I wouldn't go into this now of
course strategically without doing any
analysis this house black's pawn
structure my pawns are together because
a pawn can't move you can imagine some
king of pawn endings in this pawn
structure where if you were in zoogs
along with y you could play like a three
or a four but now you know you can't do
any of that unless you're in my camp
here that you could do it safely because
your punt doesn't want the sign that's
great so if you're white here my camp
you'll just get a queen
you're no problem but if you're an
advanced class and you know on passant
then it's not so good yeah so I can't
show this following my can because I
have confused them okay so my opponent
played King III and he just thought he'd
waive W draw just wait around
King to three King III it's worth the
wait
so if you want to win with black and
your post gets like King d3k III look
what's the winning try I would give you
a hint but it would give it away I can't
even give you the hint so I want the
answer and I want the hint otherwise
don't answer
why would when I give Ken last what
hints would I give yeah you got the
answer in the end very good yeah
yeah c4 yeah now if I play c3 I'm pretty
happy so he took and I took now I want
to do that and he doesn't get to move
yes no so he played he stopped it anyone
I find was that
okayyyy - otherwise I do what I said
okay
now if I want to win I have to calculate
if I do the ad and he does that and we
both queen and stuff like that which I
already calculated otherwise I can't win
so I got to do this and everybody tries
to win everybody's happy
okay and when I calculated this there's
only one move here I had to calculate
even though White has 11 yeah White has
11 legal was right Grandmaster West okay
well I only looked at one the other ten
I don't even I don't look at at all
because I have easy win against all ten
the same win this move I can't play the
move I would win with so I have to
analyze it so let me ask it this way it
was blacks move what's a really easy way
for black to win with no calculation
necessary you're like let me calculate
I'll get back to you f5 I'd have to
calculate I'm too old for that
well actually was 1990 so you're right I
was I was young too 99 I could have
calculated it there yeah so I have
passed pawns and he has a passed pawn so
if I stop his fast fun I'm done
calculating so I just go here and then I
pop the stance bond and then he can't
stop my two pawns he can block them but
I take his bond
so my go here I went immediately I just
stopped his bond and you all know except
maybe for a couple of you when the plugs
are connected or even when they're not a
king can't take both of them because we
take the back plant i Queen the forward
point so for example I'll give you a
good example that's a good example okay
so I go win his pawn gray and even if he
plays well actually I would play a five
here doesn't matter and you could never
take the back pawn because I Queen the
front pawn and taking the front pawn
only happens in my chess camp and then
white would win I take all the pawns and
good for white in my chess camp yeah
they don't care about legal moves too
much okay so my opponent stopped all of
my evil intentions he played
he stopped king g6 and yeah
now he's gonna Queen I hate when that
happens
you know what I like though when I Queen
first yeah exactly man that was a really
complicated Pulp Fiction quote Wow okay
you got a really no pulp fiction I
understand that but I do okay so we
cleaned look at the Fisher movie both
queens writing take his queen okay
now if I trade Queens then I win because
I have a past eeep line
I don't trade Queens it'll check me for
another 27 years I hope you'll give the
lecture okay but even when the end game
started before I played c4 I saw this
position and I could force the trade of
Queens unfortunately I'm not a genius
because every move trades Queens
according to the engine all of them do
so yeah I played one of them so he could
never go to the a file because I'll
check and take his queen he could never
go to this diagonal because I'll check
and take his queen
and he can not go to these squares um
because I'll play Queen d5 check we b5
check as my plan I don't care if it's
legal I'm a grandmaster now it's funny
grinding in 1990 that was an IM then for
a short while okay
and my rating was higher than than it is
now okay so obviously there's a lot of
moves he can't make he can't play king
c6 because i secured his king and queen
plays king c-4 I play Queen d4 checked
he has two legal moves and then I play
Queen d5 check and trade Queens so he
played king b5 and I play Queen B -
check again you can't ever go to the a
file you can't go to c6 and it doesn't
matter if you go to c4 c5 I got check
and check so he resigned here but I'll
play them out for your identification
and I could win this I'm good yeah and
the same so when I played c4 I saw the
final position but in this position when
he played rook legs before
he didn't really have an idea to draw
except it with his King back and forth
and then I have to play C for to try to
win and I win so yeah it wasn't a good
move on his part but for a lot of people
they're like well that's too complicated
and that's too far ahead I agree so you
shouldn't play rook takes before then if
it's too complicated too far ahead
you're like I hope this draws I mean see
the thing is if I take his rook any
plays B takes e4 check my King's going
back I won't do that
so if he's not worried about me playing
Rick takes rook then why is he taking my
rook unless he sure it draws when losing
so yeah not good and I didn't talk to
him after the game because I don't and
if I did I forgot good scuse okay well
thank you for coming now I have five
more positions so this is very funny I
have a funny story about this game I'm
sure Ken West could talk about games he
played in 1990 and tell me stories about
the game that I related to chest okay so
this is an Antwerp which is in what
country that's not a country that was
grand mr. Ken West anyone you think it's
Belgium because it is and I lived in
Belgium so there you go
I lived in Brussels of course and swarf
known for diamonds yeah that you and
know Michael Spencer was yeah okay so I
wasn't sure what the answer so I walk
over that little get it at home like
looking in the dictionary what what's
going on okay so the reason this game is
funny is somewhere around time control
like move 40 my brother was visiting be
in Europe during the tournament and he
drove me to the tournament he rented a
car I'd have a car in Europe and he said
you know he's gonna drive around and
look at Antwerp which I've never done
so I played chess there anyway he came
back at some point and I was still
playing of course Karen knows I'm
talking about when we come back she's
still playing so anyway we got some 40
and I was walking around and he said
I'm thinking to going to the zero or
maybe your games could end in a minute
and well what do you think and I said
this games never good ants you can leave
and just never come back we come back
maybe I'll be done either guy and he
left in my game ended in two minutes so
I stayed around like an hour waiting for
my fault
so always your opponent can make a
horrible blunder then where's your ride
right okay
so I took the bishop because I'm good
and we got to this position and you can
argue who's better because both sides
have advantages Black has a lot more
space on the Kings side but I'm not sure
that's good for him or me either his
he's closing in on my king or his king
has no defense I'm not sure which um
it's nice really good and tells my
bishop I don't know I'd know one thing I
have the D file and he has the C file
but you know so I can't like do anything
there no comment
that would give you too much information
we'll talk about it after okay so my
opponent played Queen e5 because you
should always play in the center yeah
okay
and I attacked his rook because they
might not see it well you guys at home
didn't see it there any move did um now
I thought the Queen was good on e5 and
he could either move his Queen back
towards this game for defense we could
try to infiltrate and attack me so I
gave him the choice I'm like what are
you gonna do show me what you got right
don't sue me Rick and Morty yeah so I'm
lying I you get to come in here are you
to go back there got to make a decision
now I know this guy Zack I haven't seen
him maybe since this game but he's a
very aggressive person in general so
he's not going back so he played here
now the engine says like add that pawn
doesn't matter just go here are ok but
I'm always very scared because he was a
big guy so I played here ok and I figure
I'll play Rick g6 when I feel like it
but I'm not going to lose any pawn
okay and again it's unclear to me
whether black pushing all as kingside
plunge is giving him an attack or just
making his King exposed and it's
probably just unclear sometimes you do
one or the other
luckily in this particular position it
seems to me my bishop is dominating his
night this night doesn't really have I
mean if Knight has d3 but I take it but
that's pretty good square d3 but I
stopped Knight e3 with all my pieces
okay he played h4 which I agree with
might as well check mainly and I played
work d6 and he played a very passive
move here but when the game started the
engine said it preferred white and now
it really prefers Wyatt I think it
doesn't like Queen B - because Queen B -
like pretends to threaten stuff but the
computers like this there's no threat
there so the computer for first black
defending and being worse than attacking
and losing quickly now this is rule 41 I
don't know what's going on I might lose
it one room I get made in the back rank
I might win so my brother went to the
zero I think if I get a comment on my
youtube video my brother that was in the
zoo I went somewhere else probably
stealing diamonds I don't know oh wait
that was snatch
okay so he played rugby seven if fruit
be sevens right then I don't want to be
right wait wait a mezzo go yeah Rick b7
you can't do that we're can't be on b7 I
see a lot of low rated players doing
that they make the most passive move in
chess history and they're like my puns
attacked and I'm like yeah but your
works on b7 get pledged just like that
supposed to butcher pieces active so he
did and then he's like my pugs attacked
so slightly inconsistent okay I was
younger than so I wasn't scared
so I played Queen b5 now I'd be afraid
of getting mated because there's nothing
you're my king but back in 1991 I would
actually calculate that's why my reading
was higher than it is
okay and yeah I got it I got a lot of
batteries going on here so the computer
is not going to die
batteries everywhere okay now he played
four tricks but as we all know ya never
been with a club before right so you've
seen my videos yeah that's at least one
of them yeah okay
so he played rook g7 and I was like all
right Rick d8 where are the computer
action wants me to take a pawn what a
greedy computer okay and I wanted to
play Queen a8 and made that seem like
good plan okay and he decided to
checkmate me by playing Queen c1 now he
never really has that crankbait because
as we all know I always have my favorite
move yeah Bishop f1 so I'm not ever
getting needed okay now he knew I could
play Bishop f1 so in this position he
played a really crazy move now he is
losing but his move is super losing
because he tried to trick me and here he
already has a queen c1 check as a
blunder but he played for one trick so
it was like a one-minute game as was
okay what is a slow game so so anyway
about three moves ago my brother left
for whoever he was going and then my
game ended here so hideaway now one of
the reasons he's not mating me is my
bishop controls f1 so he tried to
dissuade me from controlling f1 and this
is an endgame lecture but I want to let
you guys know when it's an endgame of
Queens on the board or Queens and rooks
there's a lot of checkmating going on in
fact I've won and lost a lot of games in
the endgame because my opponent wasn't
thinking about maybe cuz there's an
endgame so they made their King unsafe
and with my two pieces left on the board
I still needed them so you always gotta
think of checkmate
so my opponent played nine takes b3
which I'm sure you're all thinking about
by Ken and the idea is if
I take then he plays h3 check i play the
only legal move my bishops not covering
f1 anymore so he plays check and he
keeps checking me and then I get maded
yeah so he knew I couldn't take his
Knight
so he figured upon his upon and the
engine says that's a terrible move not
because of what I did which was the best
but a lot of other news when to is like
you don't want your night on b3 and you
don't to give me a free move okay but
after night b3 I have a beautiful end
that is very funny I've shown this to
many students some of them solve it
really quickly some don't solve it
quickly
my favorite was Dmitry Gurevich I was in
the chess camp in Vegas and he walked
into my class because I was ending and
he was starting sort of like here when
that guy left and I showed up yeah and
he was like oh he saw these papers I had
and he saw this position on one of the
papers and he looked he looked he's like
I don't know and then I Sherman is like
oh I like that can I keep this I was
like okay so he kept this a photos have
it now it was probably like 15 years ago
yeah
so he liked the answer so you have to
like it too he's better than you maybe
not Grand Master kind of last anybody
else he would like that
Queen SEC work Zack all these visitors
are like from Chicago pretty aggressive
free pretty aggressive you know yeah
what well Grand Master says Rick to h8
so I defer better than mine move
although I did play Rick h8 that's true
and then I waited an hour for my brother
he said you told me that he was gonna
take a long time like I don't know
Queeny it also wins it takes like 10
moves where KJ doesn't take very long
I like mating my opponent when every
move is check I prefer that I could
analyze that especially when they have
one legal move I like that now what
Grandmaster
yeah close enough if it wasn't you
wouldn't win letter bg8
now Rick g8 I'm good at analyzing I'm
good at that
and this I'm also gonna be analyzing go
Grand Master you didn't see it when you
set your hook
what no no comment okay yeah yeah uh oh
I have made that lucky
yeah right so yeah I guess this King
wasn't it's funny his rook on g7 that's
the worst you really need g7 for your
king yeah Rick Rick on g7 that's not
good defense yeah okay so I played Rick
h8 and he designed
ah yep okay and I take if I want to pawn
also if I move again and I play King G -
I mean I'm gonna play Rick a cheat mate
and still meet you I'm still threatening
that made yeah but if you don't if you
stop it up like King G - then your
h-bonds was gone so yeah King G - is
pretty safe but when you have an H pawn
it's not yeah and he did something which
I tell my students they do a lot and
eventually they stopped no they don't
I bet Larson did they fade it played
pretty good and I gasps good enough Ken
west specialty place 2800 strength plays
like yeah okay I was yeah yeah so he
played pretty well that game and then
when I started showing you the game he
didn't play well yeah before they played
fine but that's he said that's enough I
play good enough he was a visitor from
the Netherlands I was living in Belgium
so he should let me win right that make
sense make a lot of sense okay that's
like a funny story though when I lived
in Belgium I played in the tournament
and I won top Belgian and the other
Belgians were like wait a minute in that
Belgian and then they were like yeah he
lives here so he gained the table
Belgium prize
they said if there was a top American
prize would he win it and they were like
he better win it so yeah it was very
suspicious
yeah why not okay all right so I got
this position in France okay and you can
see we're in France because it looks
like white likes to retreat with this
Queen on g1 right then Simon yeah okay
so this position is pretty drawing right
because it's really drawn okay but I
don't like draws rawr so I play on and
on and on and then when you fell asleep
an analog clock I turned it when I don't
have that unclogged clocks now okay the
kids don't get it
look what's today I want o'clock they
can't cheat anymore the digital clocks
how you supposed to hi I know I can
cheat you're telling me okay so I put my
opponent to sleep I put him to sleep and
I play Queen d4 I'm hoping he takes and
I take with a pawn
that's bad fun that's better than I got
now and he's like now you have a past
bond
okay so nothing happens nothing happens
it's like The Blair Witch Project
nothing happens nothing happens that's
the end of the lecture based pissed
right okay we're calf 1 there and now in
a strange turn of events again I try to
trade Queens because if we take I think
I can sort of get in there and make it
hard form probably it's a draw but it's
my kings getting really active sometimes
I wouldn't the King upon ending
sometimes I wouldn't complain endings
probably a draw but he didn't see the
reason for that just I can't do anything
he didn't care
now he tried to trade Queens and I was
like well my kings that is good here and
his work can start attacking my plums
because his rook will get active the
first active piece he has in the game so
I didn't trade Queen that was funny and
nothing happened I threatened mate he
didn't see Queen G to mate so I won no
that's not true he played he did see it
5050
queen g1x she loses material wrote gy a
queen g1 i play rich G - I'm tricky yeah
yeah so you play crook g1 and I was like
darn alright
nothing happened and usually if you move
around a lot nothing happens they sort
of ease up though yeah he's just kidding
he's moving around doing nothing and in
this position he played rook e1 here and
he played the losing move not easy to do
notice his rooks attack with check so he
stopped that and his moves to lost 2/3
it actually reminds me of the previous
game because the previous game the
reason I was meeting my opponent was his
rook was like walking his King so this
guy did a good job repeating that always
repeat what was the dumb move that he
played clean before queenie first
probably fine you're too good you try to
make a bad move and it's fine yeah he
played rid g1 safe the only thing I can
attack is this G to pawn and what's the
winning move all at once everybody
anybody
and they're screaming at home quiet
they can hear you that's how they work
you're screaming the wrong answer but
it's okay
no Grand Minister Ken West wants to
weigh in
Wow man Grandmaster Ken let's go take a
look we're going through the quotes away
yeah let 6f3
now when I played rook takes f3 now I'm
really going to surprise now Ken West
they going to get this one what is the
main move I analyzed here what was the
move I was concerned with I wasn't
concerned with and hanging matin one
that didn't concern me he takes my rook
I play clean extreme a that wasn't
concerning but I was concerned with
something where I'll clean here that I
mean doesn't concern me just a move I
move my rook I'm caught up
yeah you had the right piece though yeah
what's the move you would never play
that's the answer now I'll give you a
little help I never play a lot of moves
I have a lot of suggestions yeah this is
the move I was I was analyzing yeah
right Ken goods like what yeah so I know
why's this this defend my queen so he
has to take it and then move his king
somewhere and I go here and then never
play f6 lives long and I win yeah if my
pub was already on f6 I would not win so
I had that extra tempo yeah and then
okay and then and then there'll be
stripper chest because I'll take it all
off and that getting cut okay good he
just instantly no absolutely not yeah
all right okay so if Queen takes g5
check would draw I wouldn't play trick
f3 although I don't know what I would
have done we've got to put anyway and
hope he didn't play it okay so he played
some random legal move I'm a pawn up in
his he punted him a lot yeah but I
actually give a pawn a way to made him
because mating your opponent's good I
learned a lot from a game I
lost with somehow I haven't shown yet a
lots of somebody famous half of you have
heard of them
more than a half more than a half now
I'm going crazy how to say more than
half
David Bronstein Wow he shook his head
wow you shook your head you like given
all the right answers I mean the guy
played for world championship with Bob
Manik you're a little by your Karen yeah
you you have you I don't
yeah and you have of course man what it
in so now my wife have you ever like air
some people say Bronstein Kara's
Korchnoi heard the three great and
Rubinstein those are the ones they like
to put in there without morphe hag I got
him all right yeah Bronstein was ahead
by a game after 22 games in the 24 game
match and he was better in game 23 and
he lost I should show that in game and
then he again shows a tie and and those
days you just whoever the champion of
the champions so so he played one match
the World Championship it was 12 to 12
and ba flick retained his title
so Bronstein would have been world
champion if things that turn out
differently in 23 then you would heard
of him oh yeah Bob the Nick Bronstein
yeah I know him um I actually played
bronze tee more than once I won once I
lost once I was gonna drop again Majan
the draw yeah I imagine that and I
talked to him a lot and he was a pretty
bitter anyway I lost the quita druk
ending where I was better and I too
passed pawns sounds good but he mated me
so I lost yeah well you you try to meet
somebody with the queen of the rook
you're gonna mate almost at Queen rook
so I tried to make this guy have a queen
and look and his king is not doing well
yeah he defended with his queen not a
good idea yeah okay now he played four
tricks but that didn't work because it
was 1992 now it worked but 92 I was good
so if he moves his Queen to the h-file
Queen f3 is pretty good right
a motorcyclist agrees to pick that up
probably he was just queen somewhere
else queen h6 check clean age to work
age 3 is good clean edge to
Green check and ERK age 30 so he played
four tricks
Rick f-100 sneaky so I think he was
hoping to go into the worst slash loss
to [ __ ] on endgame Queen g4 Queen g3 and
her g1 I think this is what he was
hoping for I think and I'm winning here
too but now he can keep playing because
he doesn't get made it but I played a
quicker win which I already told you so
it makes it easier yeah HX but yeah
closer yeah if you do notation you'd
actually be ready master yeah and he
resigned because his only legal move is
this wait I didn't see King g1 am no
good yeah King g1 I play rook takes
Queen check where I play Queen III check
and torture Amano
and then Rick h3 and I'm gonna clean up
so dead drop position i won because you
missed one tactical trick because I put
in asleep
yeah which an endgame you can put people
asleep checkmate them wait that's the
same game Wow
what ok last but not least
although least at least ok so as you all
know there's a grant there's many grand
ministers of the area we're having the
grand chest or well we were and we have
Grandmaster yes or Sarah Wan Grandmaster
Christian korilla I've been called a
grandmaster Grandmaster Ali Hongbin
Ramirez is doing Spanish commentary even
though his Spanish as if he and the
other Grandmaster that's in town there's
probably more employing missing a few is
Eric Hansen he's doing the camp with me
he's usually sitting here lecturing the
kids and they're throwing things at him
not because they're kids they just don't
like they what Eric can't forget stuff
throw normal he's a chess block United
so this game was played so long ago that
I was higher rated than him that's how
long ago was seven years ago
now his rating is 200 points higher and
mine 60 points lower that's fair
so he was 17 during this game and I
decided to play really quickly and throw
the win away and he thought yeah your
winnings he played faster when I wanted
that when the game ended we used an
engine we were like oh we're not very
good so for a long time I thought this
was an easy win because I'm cleaning and
his King can't come because my work is
stopping him I got an extra pawn just in
case so I thought this is no problem
and he played c6 and here black has one
way to win and it's very tricky and the
move I played does not win and I just
thought oh this is easy king to d6 is
very risky to the rug g8 check man if
King d6 did was erect the a track that
would be a really good move then you
have nothing yeah unfortunately
I've done that before in Belgium I was
playing in a game 30 against Richard
Paulo track and I am who so and I am and
we were checking back and forth I didn't
want to draw up a new draw and instead I
played something like King d6 and he's
skewered my king and rook and beat me so
I didn't draw alright so this requires a
lot of calculation and understanding and
weirdness so I played the obvious move
which I say never to play you watch all
my videos never play I guess he doesn't
write or extrapolate a little black n
West
okay f3 that's the way to play it didn't
did that
what so mad I mean I'm black so I'm
going that way I'm black black black I'm
always at the bottom case my comer comes
in well I say never plan me with white
so I'm half kidding
and I'm half king when I say anyway so
I'm 1/4 kidding way am I not sure much
I'm kidding anyway I'm right because f3
is a horrible blunder and I'll explain
why guys then I'll go that constrain
their way to win so this position white
has one move that draws maybe we just
playing fast so I want yeah so I'm going
to Queen so you should stop me but he
didn't stop me so I cleaned so what
moves fast II from cleaning recommended
by me he's like it's too obvious you
want to answer yeah he's a c'mon too
easy
yeah but we have a saying in chess that
you know Grandmaster Kenda last works
blowing behind passed pawn yeah Rick FA
so you should have played rook f8 and
now I was gonna play king e4 I don't
even see another room playing Rick have
25 C 7 so I just thought I'm winning
like no problem
he plays King C 5 and now my back pawn
is not too important
obviously if my pawn wasn't here this is
the dead draw this is weary to draw but
with this pawn you would think I get
some King upon anything and then Queen
by pon now where I get a rook and pawn
in Queen my plop I can't do anything so
for example if I play e5 why not use my
pawn g7 rook check King d6 and I can't
move I don't have any moves I can't play
King III because I'm not going to save
my pawn men Hill Queen and my pawns week
95 I can't play up to
play it for a win but now I got I can't
win my back pawn which I saw would help
me win doesn't do anything yeah you like
white in this position you like wise ry
playing for win yeah yeah he Queens yeah
and I take right yeah yeah I mean I'll
draw but I'm not even better
I'll draw cuz I'll make him sack has
work for my pond yeah I drew I was lucky
yeah but I mean like I can't win at all
so if he played Rick at bay he would
have drawn and I would have been very
upset because I was just playing fast
yeah
now if I play the right move here I'm
winning I have to play Rick see one
check the reason is this forces him to
make a decision if he plays King D 3
then I take and I win I'm two points up
ok so he has to make the decision of
king b5 okay and now I play f3 and if he
plays Rick a faint you might say wait a
minute this looks like what we looked at
before but let's go back when I played
f3 and he played here another when he
didn't play here in this position if I
play rook here check and he plays king
b5 that transposes to what we just
looked at which was a win for black but
he doesn't play king b5 I didn't check
him right away so he could play king d3
now if he play King g3 with his rook on
h8 and my plot on f4 I'm just winning
now I don't want anything I take his
blind takes my pawn as a draw
so that's funny like sometimes Kings c5
draws sometimes King G three draws so
what I have to do is play rook check
first and then he can do both he has to
pick the one that I can beat I can beat
either one of them as long as I know
which one he's doing obviously I could
be king g3 because I take upon two pawns
up okay he plays King g5 and I play up
three
he plays Rick FA
now I have one move that wins I'm not
even sure I would find it in the game
even if I played it correctly I might
not find it here because the obvious
move is kinging 4 and that's a draw it
look it's good for black but the
computer draws anyway but I will move
there wins pretty easily that I might
not have found you want to play right I
can't win playing wrong I won quickly
that's the way to do it but the wrong
move the guy plays the wrong move back
and you win for the right move it's
tough extra plums not as good as I
thought it was
I hope so if I play the right variation
I will clean the e pawn after we're done
way after we're done we're gonna stop
way before that
I'm slower because I everybody was wrong
all meiosis is wrong
sometimes you have to give up clothes
slightly better than g6 yeah King D 5
yeah because this way you're going to
win the pawn you're getting the
opposition so you can check them and
force them to the a file and you can
also play King G for King D so for
example if you check to me now I have
the right Tempe his rooks not behind my
pawn anymore so if he goes behind my
pawn I got a free kingi foreign then I
can win by one tempo and see anything so
now when he takes my pawn I once again
have one move that wins
Rick we want ya this King was the a
thought doesn't matter where I take and
this is an easy win because his King
doesn't exist and the computers like
announces made already your stuff yeah
so the only way to win from this
position was Rick check and then F 3 and
then King D 5 right so I won quicker
because I played worse yeah so I oh yeah
I played out three and rook F eight
draws and he played c7 hit and now every
move wins if you say a reasonable move
you'll win Rick C ones reasonable I play
the quicker one but Rick see one wins
I played f2 and the thing is I'm
threatening the Queen I don't care if he
Queens because if he Queens I'm going to
check and take his queen I don't care if
he Queens he does care if I Queen
because I'm quitting with Jack so he
cares a little bit but if he Queens I
just check and take it so he played rook
f8 thinking I might play rook check and
then he would play king d3 and then if I
take and he takes it to draw again but
again I don't care if he Queens
so I queen I'll carefully check and then
he designed because if he takes and
takes he's not threatening the Queen
because I have this the good player is
always lucky
so when the game ended life is like I
was always winning no problem and then
when else was an engine I was like oh
that's a blunder that's abundant it's a
blunder yeah so yeah after the move c7
I'm winning again yeah teach him to try
to Queen gets me yeah and then we don't
play very well
they make us teach camp upstairs to
little five-year-olds you can't make
legal moves that's what we do now yeah
and some of them can make legal moves
because of us were pretty good teachers
yeah most of them can but yeah yeah and
also I showed this game recently to
Nakamura and he thought the game would
conclude f1 equals Knight CA equals 9
and then and then we both resigned right
right Bensimon yeah now he knows yeah
and I was like we didn't do that
but we considered it yeah and that's why
because of this game and all the night
promotions
what did I do two months ago three
months ago I'd beat mama John off see I
was able to do that with only all denied
promotions yeah all right that was end
game double X clam plus tax
[Music]